katia le défilé est arrivé du côté de la
place de la nation
quel bilan faut-il retenir de cette
journée
[Applaudissements]
cgt annoncé cent trente mille
manifestants ce qui paraît assez
crédible puisque nous avons monté tout
le cordage il est vraiment interminable
on peut pas dire qu'ils arrivent ils
arrivent depuis trois quarts d'heure
donc elle est vraiment la fréquentation
est tous rendez vous il ya ici tous les
corps de métiers de la chanteuse d'opéra
aux éboueurs en passant par les
enseignants les cheminots les égouts tic
ont d'ailleurs fait une très belle mise
en scène avec des cercueils et des
cordes ont vraiment toutes professions
très inquiète par cette réforme alors
évidemment le taux de grévistes est plus
bas aujourd'hui mais il faut dire que
selon leurs propres termes il a ils sont
en grève depuis plus de deux mois en
tout cas il était vraiment très nombreux
et je vous propose d'écouter certains
manifestants donc très inquiet à cause
de la réforme de 7,2 rétracte les
enseignants étant pas extraordinaire
mouvement bien payé ils sont assez bien
payé en fin de carrière est en fin de
carrière
on va la retraite est calculé sur les
six derniers mois
maintenant ça serait calculée sur les 25
dernières années
du coup il y aura une perte de retraite
d'environ 30%
c'est ce que disent à peu près les gens
même les économistes qui sont pas mais
qui peuvent être au mouvement pro
réformes le disent on ne prend pas en
compte la pénibilité du travail
or en tant qu'aide soignante infirmières
il ya des gens qui sont restés en
catégorie b pour bénéficier de la
pénibilité du travail et de la prise en
compte de la catégorie active donc qui
sont restés dans leur lit de catégorie b
et ne pas passer en catégorie à
c'était un choix d'options il ya dix ans
elles l'ont fait et aujourd'hui on leur
annonce que finalement la pénibilité
la carrière actifs ne sera pas pris en
compte vous rendez compte c'est un
scandale c'est des gens qui comme en ont
perdu du pouvoir d'achat et qui
aujourd'hui se retrouvent à pouvoir à
devoir travailler s'étendent plus
minimum donc de nombreux points
contestés par les manifestantes qui
composent cette réforme et puis à la
peur que les services publics soient
abandonnées au fur et à mesure alors
l'examen de cette fameuse réforme a
démarré lundi en commission à
l'assemblée nationale il ya plus de 22
mille amendements apportés par les
parlementaires de l'opposition inquiète
pas qui évidemment la conte est un tout
tout comme les personnes dans la rue et
la réforme arrivera dans l'hémicycle à
partir du 17 février jour où les
syndicats ont prévu une journée noire
notamment dans les transports
[Musique]